what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another a song of ice and fire
video
well folks once again george rr martin
has missed another deadline that he set
upon himself
the internet was absolutely on fire
yesterday as hundreds or even
thousands of fans were making fun of
george rr martin because another
deadline has come and gone without any
announcements of him having the winds of
winner done
and in hand now just in case you're
wondering what i am referring to
let me back up a little bit this all
started because of something george r
martin said
on his not a blog back in may of last
year
this is what he said in the summer of
2020 wellington is hosting the world
science fiction convention
the oldest and most important con in the
science fiction
fantasy calendar and they've asked me to
serve as toastmaster for the hugo awards
writers fans and artists from all over
the world will be headed down to check
out all of your wonders
i hope lots of you kiwis will join us of
course
i was especially moved by your offer to
bring me to new zealand on
us how wonderfully generous as it
happens
i do have enough money to make it to new
zealand on my own
but there are many american writers fans
and artists who do not
if you'd care to fly say 20 or 30 or 50
of them to wellington in place of me
i have no doubt they would instantly
accept and fall in love with middle
earth
or new zealand just as i have and you
have such big planes
i'm sure you could squeeze them in as
for finishing my book
i fear that new zealand would distract
me entirely too much
best leave me here in westeros for the
nonce but i tell you this
if i don't have the winds of winter in
hand when i arrive in new zealand for
worldcon
you have here my formal written
permission to imprison me
in a small cabin on white island
overlooking that lake of sulfuric acid
until i'm done just so long as the acid
fumes do not screw up my old dos word
processor
i'll be fine so as you can see over a
year ago
george r martin said he would have the
winds of winner finished by the summer
well it's now the summer of 2020 and
george has yet to deliver the next book
in fact it sounds like he's not even
close to having it finished
he gave us another wins of winner update
very recently and this is what he said
i have to confess after half a year of
pandemic
quarantine and social distancing i am
showing signs of cabin fever
half of a witch is quite literal in my
case yes
i am in an actual cabin in the mountains
no i have no fever
yay for the present at least i am
healthy
for an out-of-shape guy at 71 at least
and doing all that i can to stay that
way if nothing else
the enforced isolation has helped me
right i am spending
long hours every day on the winds of
winter and making steady progress
i finished a new chapter yesterday
another one three days ago and another
one the previous week
but no this does not mean that the book
will be finished tomorrow or published
next week
it's going to be a huge book and i still
have a long way to go
i was heartbroken when khan zealand was
forced to go
virtual due to the pandemic and i have
to cancel my plans
exciting plans for a long trip down to
wellington with paris and my minions
but there is definitely a silver lining
in that cloud
the last thing i need right now is a
long interruption that might cost me
all my momentum i have built up i can
always visit wellington next year
when i hope that both covet 19 and the
winds of winner will be done
i still plan to host the hugo awards and
fulfill all the rest of my toastmasterly
duties for worldcon
and have started pre-recording some bits
for the ceremony
a wise precaution since i am hopeless
with zoom
and skype and like things but that is a
lot less time consuming
and distracting than flying to the other
end of the world
in between tapings i returned to
westeros
of late i have been visiting with cersei
osha
tyrion sir barristan and area hota
i will be dropping back into bravo's
next week i have bad days which get me
down
in good days which lift me up but all in
all i am pleased with the way things are
doing
i do wish they would go faster of course
way way back in 1999
when i was deep in the writing of a
storm of swords i was averaging about
150 pages of manuscript a month
i fear i shall never recapture that pace
again
looking back i am not sure how i did it
then a fever indeed
well george r martin should be in new
zealand as we speak
with the winds of winter in his hand but
as you can see
he is not in new zealand and the book is
far from finished
this is something we have seen from him
over and over again
year after year now to be honest with
you i'm not even mad about him missing
another deadline
i never expected him to actually have
the book done by this summer
what i don't understand is why he keeps
giving himself these deadlines when he
knows he'll never make them
he has even said that he is done
announcing deadlines because he has
missed every one
but for some reason he has done it here
again he says he still has a long way to
go
and he hopes he can have it done by next
summer when new zealand has another
convention
by then it will have been a decade since
the dance with dragons was released
all i can do now is hold out hope that
he will get it done sometime soon
whenever the winds of winter does come
out i expect it to break the internet
as well as breaking records for the
amount of sales a song of ice and fire
was already a very successful series of
books but after that disaster of a
finish we got from game of thrones
i think the anticipation for the winds
of winter is through the roof
however with that being said let's look
at another update from george rr martin
he said this just a little over a week
ago this writing stuff is hard
even so it has been going well of late
three more chapters completed this week
and good progress on several more
still a long long way to go though do
not get too excited
yikes no matter how long it actually
takes
i am very confident we will get the ones
of winter and it will most likely be one
of the greatest books of all time
but at this rate i am not so sure about
the dream of spring
for now it will have to remain a dream
for those of you that don't know i am
making videos on every chapter from
every book and a song of ice and fire
i have only recently started but it
looks like i will have enough time to
get them finished before the next book
is released
i think if you haven't had a chance to
read the books yet
head over to my most recent videos i am
making videos on each chapter
letting you know what happens in the
books starting from the very beginning
i would love to see you there anyways
let me know what you all think about
these different updates from george rr
martin
do you think he will ever finish a song
of ice and fire
leave your thoughts down below i would
love to see what you have to say
if you would like to support my channel
consider heading over to my patreon
i would really appreciate that either
way i hope everyone has a great day
i will see you again very soon with my
next chapter video
bye
[Music]
[Music]
um
you